I'll Reza back-to-back victories for you
but most importantly I think it's for
the first time that you're beating a
world champion you fight against Magnus
uh quite a few times you didn't manage
to get him while he was a world champion
but now you got your first scalp over
world champion how do you feel right now
yeah I feel really happy
um and for sure it's easier to Champion
than Magnus so of course thing is very
strong
um I'm really happy to get this Victory
because now I moved to plus one and it's
really important and this game was not
easy you were actually under pressure
out of the opening out of the middle
game and I think at one point he was
even winning he showed you a move at the
end of the game what was that move it
was
um should we go to the position
absolutely
um it was around here I think I hear him
out he got outplayed here actually
um I think
G6 is a terrible move to Vic to make the
king weak but already I don't like each
five which were just Knight C5 is just
econ
he was a bit aggressive and
maybe he failed to be like he has to be
aggressive because he doesn't have two
Bishops so but yeah he took here here I
couldn't find the
best move Bishop A2 is really difficult
oh
first I thought he was the plan of this
bishop it's just prophylactic
preventing Knight D6 which was the whole
problem for me the whole game first I
saw that I'm winning with Queen C2 in my
calculation but of course Queen C5 and I
lose this was the first cold shower and
and then um
I felt like G5 yeah Bishop way too
problem meaning but yeah Knight G5 is
not a good move on here he's okay I
couldn't make bishop for work for me
because Knight H5 is probably just
nothing Queenie five Queen D7 very
important yeah and
so I decided just hanging on with this
Knight on D6 defending everything but I
felt like I should not be worse here my
Bishop 182 so H4 okay phone here normal
but yeah I'm probably like my Bishop on
D2 is very bad and
and in fact I want to chime in on this
position how did you assess it at this
point because I came into the playing
Hall and you were I think down to your
last six minutes he still had around
double your time yeah it was getting out
of my hand and it was getting out of my
control because in preview previous
moves I was in control and then I lost
the control and I got down on time but
you still looked comfortable yeah
because at least from the outside yeah
because practically there is always a
chance here because with the bishop 182
but
um so he was also going down on time so
it was very important moments here
um
yeah he told me after the game Knight D4
that he probably was winning but still I
saw Knight F7 and he told me Rook D2
after the game but I don't think it's a
good one here it's Rook D2 and this
seems to somehow yeah he told me Luke 62
1962 be sure he's seeking his son Rook
F4 he told me he has no idea but I told
him I have things and I've been again
but it's such a complicated position
yeah yeah it's really complicated and
understanding for instance computers is
drug test the one is winning here is
really crazy because you're giving up
the D file for no like and then you plug
it with nine yeah okay this is Knight F2
Knight F2 okay yeah and for human for
instance to all I have all this bishop
H6 Knight G5 it's difficult yeah so
um yeah for was it only move Knight D4 I
think it was among the only ones yeah
it's such a complicated position and if
you don't do something as black then you
know Bishop D6 is coming you have always
problems yeah you thought for a thing
like six seven minutes he thought for a
while yeah and he settled for draw I
think in his mind he thought he is not
better anymore yeah of course if you've
seen anything before you win
uh he couldn't see it and here I think
he miscalculated 95 checking his mind
like he checked all of this and I think
he maybe here he wanted yeah yeah it's
maybe maybe I'm mistaken maybe he saw
all of this but he probably missed 95
Powers everything yeah this is so nice
so but maybe he saw it and he
voluntarily went for this position
which I think it's really hard to assist
but I thought I'm meaning yeah but it
may be strong
um it's robot even if it's raw
objectively it's much easier to play for
you yeah you have always checks and yeah
and here I was still lucky that he
didn't gain the time that he needed he
has two I think two minutes here is
rough 36 he still has yeah four moves to
make I think and he has less time than
five minutes here five minutes dropped
down to his last minute right with this
move yeah I felt he has to keep the king
here but it's still
um I wanted to go here uh maybe
activating visual
so explain to us the decision between
him going towards the center and he's
going towards I think he sat here for
three four minutes and he thought that
he's just lost and he gave up I think
and he just wanted to make some movement
in the last second and he didn't
understand that he has a still chance
probably which is also I said also that
I'm meaning now King comes C1 and so I
don't have good explanation for this and
because he left the G6 Pawn very weak so
that's why I probably just to defend
that G6 Point yeah and
yeah and the rest is just easy
I just pushed and I pushed the two
points and it's just me well alireza it
definitely feels like you warmed up and
you're finally getting your type of play
uh on the board congratulations big
victory for you today go enjoy it and
we'll see you in a couple of days thank
you very much thank you Christian thank
you alireza